normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have this from the financial review gen
Z could be the most conservative
generation ever they go out less have
less sex and lose their virginity later
what is up with young people and
teenagers and there's there's there's a
couple questions about what this really
means so let me break it down for you
very simply first Mo the most
conservative doesn't mean that jenzi as
a monolith believes certain things it
could be that 30% are super far left but
31% are super conservative and then
people in the middle are whatever so now
it's the most conservative but what I
think this actually means is you have to
when you're talking about conservative
versus Progressive you have to look at
the relativity of the previous
generations if you took someone from
1650 and compared them to Joe Biden Joe
Biden looks Progressive as they come
despite the fact that he's an old man or
more importantly like Chuck Grassley
like take like an actual Republican
who's considered a conservative compare
him to a dude from the 1600s and you're
going to be like the guy from the 1600
is backwards and you know super far
right or whatever however they describe
it so when we're when we're asking
whether not someone's conservative the
question is are they more traditional or
less traditional by the previous
generation standards and the argument
being made here is that jenz is is less
traditional than the previous generation
standards indicating they've shifted
back towards Traditional Values in a way
we have not seen in a 100 years this we
saw this we saw this data back in 2018
we are seeing it repeated over and over
and over again that suggests while jenz
probably has similar politics to
Millennials the fact that on certain
areas they've moved more traditional
more conservative this suggests jenzi is
actually the most conservative by
movement not by politics I want to make
sure that's clear MH we are not saying
that J a 20-year-old has the same
Politics as Chuck Grassley we're saying
that a 20-year-old has more conservative
views than a 35-year-old to throw a
wrench in this uh this says they go out
less have less sex and lose their
virginity later I'm sorry to tell you
guys the economy the inflation people
cannot afford to go out and because of
Tinder and crap single one wealthy guy
is getting like 10 women so those girls
aren't around to have sex with anymore
for those kids those guys those humans
right right right and and and that is a
good point based on that statement but
when you also look at what we brought up
uh previously that jenzi actually uh uh
is is aligned with Boomers on the
question of samesex marriage and the
support for samex marriage has declined
that actually suggests politically jenz
is more conservative and I think this
may be due to liberals abort their kids
and about internet it just like ideas
spread like wildfire with internet so to
conservative ideas oh you know what's
crazy and I just thinking I bet liberals
get pregnant way more than conservatives
do it's totally possible I think I think
absolutely true if conservatives if they
got pregnant three times as much but had
twice as many abortions boom or twice as
much but twice as many abortions look at
the point they're making about uh having
less sex means you're conservative
conservatives and especially Christian
conservatives very religious people are
waiting until marriage meaning
substantially less sex and pregnancies
but then they have those kids whereas
liberals they bang like crazy more power
to you but then they get tons of
abortions there there's actually some
new trends that are troubling that I've
seen that show that they the teens are
just having less sex it's not because
it's like the rise of the incels right
like they they watch porn instead of
having sex and I think there's a real
you know in Japan parents hire uh like
strippers and sex counselors for their
their young Sons because they don't
pursue women they they view their
computers as their sexual gratification
it's happening everywhere though did you
see Kim Jong-un crying no Kim Jong-un
cried begging the women of North Korea
to have more babies wow and I'm like
wait North Korea like they don't have
the internet there how are they having
less kids there of all places they they
aren't subject to the same social
pressures as the west Western countries
are what do you think causes Baby Boom
my theory is that it's an optimism in
the future right so like we the big the
big baby boom we had what all these guys
came back from winning the war in World
War II there's a huge baby boom I think
we have a different problem now I think
that there's a real pessimism in the
future and there's like a malaise that
has taken over this country and that's
why you're seeing decreased fertility
rates cuz I tell I have a lot of friends
that haven't had kids yet aren't married
and their number one thing is I don't
want to bring a kid in this world it's
so crazy and I and that that's always uh
stuck with me because I'm going the
exact opposite route I'm like no I need
more I need more kids to change the
world strongly feel like the I'm not
bringing kids into the world because the
world is terrible I feel like that's a
cope it's a c I really don't think
that's true and and I don't believe the
economy stuff either we have I've
mentioned this eight casinos within two
hours drive from where we are right now
you like these places can't exist people
are are dumping money and and some
people say well it's credit or irr
responsible like yeah sure whatever
either way people are choosing to use
what money they have on other things
it's often said there you know people
are always like we're waiting for the
right time to have kids there is no
right time no right that's a myth it
never gets easier by the way it gets
harder it it so I'm I'm 37 we had number
six when I was
36 it was tough you're you're more tired
you don't have the energy that you have
when you're 23 or 19 I had my first at
19 tons of energy I mean it was still
tough and challenging but it's gotten
harder and harder and more difficult
yeah I can afford it more but it is way
more taxing on your energy levels and
and stress we got we got Americans are
morbidly obese so it's not food so what
is it it it is interesting and and
remove it from from the United States
and look at North Korea North Korea is
having population problems and we assume
that they're starving but that clearly
food is not the issue when when Kim
jongon cries and begs his women to have
more babies it might be like a
collective Consciousness thing this is a
bit out there woo woo you would say but
I do think there's something the
collective Consciousness when like nine
people feel good and then the 10th guy
walks in the room he's he might start
feeling good too just because he can
feel the energy like that that's Global
that's in the Schuman resonance in the
in the Earth's magnetic field I think
that there's some sort of communication
but like I went through when I was 26
with this one girl we were talking about
I was like yeah I don't want to have
kids cuz what you were saying Terry I
don't want to bring them into this crap
hell hole but I knew that was kind of
fake we were saying it out loud but in
my head I was like it's not really true
though but I did say I don't want to
travel all over the world like my job's
traveling a lot of it is it has been
throughout the years and I didn't want
to leave him behind when I went and
traveled and I didn't want to be that
Dad that wasn't around like four days a
week cuz I want to tour I wanted to go
tour and I never ended up really touring
but I still want to go tour when I want
to tour but I I don't know it's
it doesn't but then the loneliness of
just getting on my computer and being
like what another one of these days like
there's more to life how is it I I think
it's just really interesting that North
Korea is experiencing this they they
rule they control culture with an iron
fist so it is interesting to see that's
happening all over the
place you know Russia when they Russia
did this huge experiment in the 1920s uh
to abolish the family and they were
really they were too successful where
they ended up having to verse course
because people weren't having kids
anymore so what they did was they I
forget the term for it but they like
basically honored mothers like if you
were a mother of x amount of kids you
were given like the ultimate worker
title and it was like the most glorious
and venerated position in the country
and they they ended up having to do a
lot to reverse it I think we're
Americans kind of chose it though in the
Soviet Union they liberalized everything
they did uh they made marriage a a f
minute dissolution process uh they made
you raise your kids away from the home
that you couldn't even have your grandma
or it's happening but Americans like
actively chose it right like we we now
are doing this whole women's lib thing
which you know I don't really care if
women work but like why why do you want
you're going to work for someone right
you're going to serve someone why not
your family why not your kids like why
do you want to work for Jeff Bezos over
these little human beings that
absolutely love you and are will do
anything to get your affection and I
just got to I got I got I got I can
simplify it
dramatically why would a woman choose to
enter a pickle jar opening contest
against a man and I'm being as silly and
absurd with it as possible the joke
being of course women can't open pickle
jars some women of course can my point
is yeah men and women are different and
men do a lot of jobs that women would
not want to do specifically due to
physical differences like carrying
bodies out of burning buildings is a job
for a man why sorry dude I there are
some women that can do it but on average
overwhelmingly it's going to be a guy
who can lift a body and pull them to
safety out of a burning building why did
society decide women should start
competing with men in their role that
led to a massive decline in birth rates
well what was look I I had I don't think
I had that unique of an experience but
my great grandmother so I'm the eldest
of an L7 El so I knew my my great-
grandmother was 6 when I was born um she
was The Matriarch like no one messed
with her she was the boss like you
didn't want to be on her bad side you
couldn't really fool her I never really
grew up with this mindset that like
women were inferior to men like it was
never even a thing I actually always
thought that like I don't want to make
Grandma mad I don't want to make my mom
mad I don't want to make you know it was
just always but so like in my mind women
have always been elevated in our family
and I I don't think that that's that
strange for most of America I think most
people would defer and do what Their
great-grandmother said or what their
mother said and so you have this weird
thing where women started fighting for
equality when they had the whole world
that someone tweeted I forget who it was
but it might have been pachy Keenan who
I'm a huge fan of but she said the
problem is is that when you Proclaim
that women can do every anything they
end up doing everything they're they're
they're the the the bread winner and the
Homemaker they you spend less time with
your kids you spend the weekends doing
all your chores and catching up on
everything and I don't know like women
were elevated in society and they were I
don't know it'sing the end result is
simple the people who have kids their
ideals will persist their genetics will
will persist and the people who don't
won't it's it's just that simple well
you were talking about roie Wade earlier
and and how and I think you're exactly
right like the the real issue with roie
Wade is it didn't allow the states to
experiment we didn't get to see how
different uh abortion limits in
different states and and and you know
and what that would produce everyone had
legalized abortion up until the moment
of birth and that was that and so now we
actually have a situation where we can
see that the results of of being a
pro-life State and how that is more
beneficial to your I think the report
was 32,000 births attributed to the
overturning of roie Wade that's huge
that ain't happening in blue States no
so if we actually see population decline
reverse in red States due to actual
human reproduction blue States will
still keep declining and then they can
bring in all the non-citizens they want
to show up their numbers but all that
matters is do human beings have access
to abortion yes no if you don't you're
going to have way more kids that's just
it basic math y'all can make every
argument to factor in every variable but
still the the the overwhelming mass is
going to be people in California they
may increase their their their
population every year by 100,000 per se
but they're not having kids so it still
will just be people aging and then
passing on and then they've got to keep
at at at the bare minimum they're just
maintaining themselves in a treadmill
what if the illegal migrants have the
kids they also can have abortions too
nothing's baring illegal immigrants from
having abortions they don't seem I don't
know this is a generalization but I in
Mexico for instance it's much more
culturally re uh acceptable to have
large families and lots of kids Planned
Parenthood tend to be in minority
neighborhoods and they target them
mercilessly with advertising and and PR
it's it's crazy you're you may be right
and I have I have considered this that
uh a different culture and it's and
we're not talking about Mexico it's not
these these illegal illegal immigrants
come from all over the world um many of
them are coming from South and Central
America they may be more religious and
less likely to get abortions but that
doesn't change the pressure system that
exists where you mentioned they're being
targeted you've got uh South Park did
that funny joke where uh South uh
Cartman is a teacher and he's telling
all the girl all the Latina girls to get
abortions and the black girls he's like
just cheat just get rid of the baby and
you can be rich do like what white
people do
but white conservatives are having kids
well here's the question then you
mentioned earlier the Soviet Union had
had given women like special benefits
for having kids and I've heard like some
countries lower tax burden up to like
100% if you have four kids you don't
have to pay any taxes at all uh so would
there be any value to doing that for
women that are illegal
immigrants in the United States I I I I
just don't I think as a matter of rules
you can't give benefits to illegal
immigrants I you can't do any incentives
for illegal immigration they're they're
breaking the law we have to control our
border but I I do think that we have to
do this for moms in America right they
it my wife works so hard and she I don't
know how she does it half the time
but it's it's almost like society looks
down on moms right like oh you're a
stay-at-home mom oh yeah that's way hard
hard than your joke of a job sending
press releases out for Google right like
as as some lowlevel person like being a
mom is a tough job and it's the most
important job in what world will you
ever have little you know your your the
people underneath you looking up to you
like children do to their mothers right
like you will never get that in the
workplace you die at you start a
successful business and you die you are
forgotten like immediately they move on
they find a replacement you don't do
that with your mom you don't do that
with your dad as long as are good you
know what I mean but like I don't know
I'm kind of ranting now but I I don't
understand the misogyny in general where
it's coming from or why I mean maybe
it's just I wasn't around it growing up
cuz I had similar to you like a femin
phenomenal mother like the family was so
legit and she was like if she said it it
happened like there was no denying her
Authority that was your experience too
yeah yeah it's coming from feminists
feem feminists want to uh so you get
feminists who want to be in masculine
roles and so they attack and attack and
attack the feminine role and now we live
in a society where the feminine role is
looked down upon it's
insulted and and they argue that they're
fighting for women I think that at the
root of all of these all of these people
these activists that are doing this I
don't think they came from Happy
households right and so what they grew
up with they end up spreading to
everyone else and they cause chaos and
dysfunction for all of us and it just
it's like a cancer it keeps spreading
and I
mean I don't know I my the women in my
family Ruled The Roost and you know what
if my wife were to say like you're not
doing this guess what I'm not doing
right like I defer to my wife on
everything she lets me lead most of the
time but at the end of the day they they
make the rules and if they come down
hard on something you're not doing it
it's not happening when I was like I
started making internet videos in 2006
and I was like 26 years old and there
was this girl I was like maybe I'll
start a family with this girl and then I
was like what would my life be like for
the next 15 years I'll just be making
internet videos of like me with my kids
what value is that going to bring to
society and now I realize oh it'll show
people how to have a happy and healthy
family thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net